another sneaky little trick is one we
learned from shakespeare
it's called the royal we uh the royal
you
and that has to do with sort of forcing
people into feeling there on your team
or to put themselves in your shoes right
so number one you want to avoid
eye whenever possible and this is hard
to do and it's a good part of that vomit
edit rule so
once you vomit things out you want to go
in and look for have you used i all over
the place
try to 86 that and replace it with we or
or you or just start with the verb in
the sentence altogether right
i makes people feel that it's all about
you the talker
and not about them and sales are all
about other people
marketing and lead gen is all about
listening and putting the other person
up front we is very inclusive
and you can do we when people aren't
exactly a we so it makes them feel like
they're a part of your team when they
aren't officially yet
and the other thing about you is that
you is actually empathy which is even
better than sympathy right because
that's like right imagining yourself
in the mix